The third chapter of The Mandalorian offered
the most explosive, action-filled scenes seen
on the series yet, and with this newest episode,
it feels as though we're truly off and running
at last.
After watching Mando clearly feel conflicted
by dropping off Baby Yoda in exchange for
all that Beskar steel, he does exactly what
we were all waiting for: busts in to steal
the baby back and kill his way out again.
After, of course, he gets sick new armor from
his blacksmith.
Chapter Three ended on a massive one-against-dozens
gunfight in the spaceport square.
When Mando is at his lowest, with no apparent
means of escape, the rest of the Mandalorian
enclave appears at the last second to help
him and Baby Yoda get to his ship and off
the planet.
That might be done, but neither of them are
safe; and if his usual spaceport is razed
and the Mandalorian enclave is scattered because
of his actions, the only thing to ask is what
happens next.
During Chapter 3, we hear The Client speak
with Dr. Pershing just before Mando bombs
his way into the compound, but the Client
seems to have already disappeared by the time
Mando makes it to Baby Yoda.
The Client clearly anticipates an attack.
"Finish your business quickly, for I can no
longer guarantee your safety."
Is this because he knows the Mandalorian's
intentions are compromised, or that having
the child at all destroys their safety?
And what's up with Dr. Pershing?
Sharp-eyed fans have noticed that the doctor
has a patch on his sleeve that bears a resemblance
to those worn by denizens of the clone-manufacturing
world of Kamino the same people who cloned
the Fetts.
If this insignia rings true, Dr. Pershing
may just want to clone Baby Yoda.
Kamino's scientists burned through thousands
of failed clones just trying to get Jango
Fett's clone prototype right.
We don't know exactly where The Client sits
in Empire hierarchy, but he looks more like
a former senator than a military officer;
his outfit is strikingly similar to Palpatine's
senatorial robes from the Star Wars prequels.
So what's The Client's true desire here?
Though small, a creature from Yoda's species
has importance because of its natural Force
sensitivity.
Perhaps the Empire is keen on returning to
the concept of a clone army... but populated
by unstoppable Force users.
That would obviously be very effective in
overturning the power of the New Republic.
The Client is interested in restoring, quote,
"the natural order of things after a period
of disarray", after all.
His sinister piece is not yet done, and we
will probably see him again.
What does Mando want?
It's been established that Mando is very suspicious
of the remnants of the Empire; he won't take
Imperial Credits as payment, even if it means
being paid less for his work.
"I don't know if you heard but the Empire
is gone."
"It's all I've got!"
Sure, he took the Baby Yoda job because he
wanted cash, but he was also in too deep to
back out gracefully once he found out that
the Empire was the actual client.
The Empire is responsible for what the Mandalorian
blacksmith ominously refers to as "the purge,"
so that's a whole lot of incentive to not
like the Empire right away.
So it makes sense that Mando would ask a lot
of questions about what's going to happen
to Baby Yoda.
But when speaking with the blacksmith, Mando
refers to the baby as his enemy, and goes
on to say that the one who assisted him in
his fight with the mudhorn was unaware that
they were enemies, which is a whole lot to
unpack.
This all raises several questions: What's
Mando looking for?
Is the baby still his enemy, and is he invested
in creating a relationship with it?
Evidence suggests the latter, since he and
his Mandalorian friends shot up a whole town
to save Baby Yoda's life.
It's all a familial excursion, implying that
while they probably don't understand what
Mando is doing, they'll support him and trust
he's acting in accord with their version of
honor.
One thing is for sure: a substantial proportion
of the scummiest citizens in the sector are
going to be after him now because of all this.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Mandalorian
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.